When working an Unreal Engine, it's important to have the right hardware for the job.
If it's your intent to animate within the engine and leverage tools like MetaHumans,
LiveLink, ControlRig, or other processor and GPU intensive tasks, Epic recommends an Intel
i9 or AMD Ryzen 9 5950X or better processor.
Gets 64GB of RAM and a solid state hard drive as well.
It's also important to choose a proper GPU.
By examining your role in production, you can make a solid choice of which car to buy.
Modellers, shading artists, and animators can be served very well by an RTX 4080, 4090,
5070 Ti, 5080, or 5090 GPUs.
Whereas lighting artists, rendering specialists, and virtual production teams are required
to use powerful GPUs with higher-end GPUs like the RTX Pro 5000 and 6000 Blackwell, RTX
6000 and 5000 Aida, or the RTX A6000 or A5000 Ampere-based cards.
When it comes to level management and organization, the best practices dictate placing all of
your commonly shared global actors into the persistent level while dividing up your action
into beats.
These beats can have their own dedicated level.
Once that's accomplished, sub-levels can help manage your scene assembly organization.
Be careful not to have too many sub-levels because that can be difficult to manage.
Level visibility can turn on and off sub-levels as the shot requires, and when rendering,
it's wise to change the streaming method for your sub-levels to Always Loaded.
This will place the sub-level into active memory for faster access.
When planning your shots, consider optimizing your foreground, mid-ground, and background
elements to ease your rendering burden.
Single-level sequences with a single camera cuts track can be great for setting up master
shots with multiple coverage cameras.
Plus it's great for simple editing.
For distinct shot-based workflows, it's recommended that you nest your level sequences together
with a shot track.
This will provide greater organization and accessibility for non-linear workflows and
makes your team work easier.
Try not to exceed more than three levels of nesting, and if you need alternates to your
shots, use the Take system to swap between level sequences.
Many people wonder what are the best practices for using actor persistence.
Choose spawnables for temporary background actors, custom shot-specific lighting, or
one-off effects.
Make sure you're not parenting to the spawnable actor because those actors will disappear
after the level sequence ends.
This will kill any parenting setup for those spawnable actors in the level.
Attached tracks or constraints might be a better idea.
Spawnables also have the advantage of reducing memory overhead for those actors who are not
in use.
As for possessibles, use these actors for fixed assets, scene environments, or characters
planned to be used throughout all shots.
Unlike spawnables, possessibles are not destroyed after the shot completes, so they're always
accessible.
We also have some resource links available for you.
These white papers, communities, and online documentation will help guide you through
potential questions you might have.
Okay, this concludes our lecture on transitioning from legacy production to Unreal Engine.
Thank you.